what's up Tara are you there I can't see
you oh my goodness you're real this is
the first time we're actually looking at
each other are you recording I'm
recording this I'm recording right now
cool yeah don't worry I want people to
just hear how we actually talk with each
other sometimes and start instead of
people always think we're just cracking
I'm cracking dick jokes the whole time
but how was your day so far oh pretty
good ran into a magnesite new gym yeah
yeah hey Steve so what's up Steve why
Stan yeah you met a fan at the gym
that's so funny I met like three or four
dudes at the gym so far now man so it's
the gym where you primarily meet people
uh yeah for the most part i mean i met
somebody a chinese food store yeah i was
going to pick up some spoon and his kids
came in and they were like yo you
tolerant man yourselves like it it was
two of them that time and one time I was
in macys but my action we ran into a
girl and then two security guards at the
cherry hill mall New Jersey they both
recognized Oh to cirque asians it was
funny man like he's like like I'm
walking downstairs it's got two levels
and her security guard on upper level
looking at you like an was looking
behind you like to see Tom like some of
me is like a third you to write yourself
yeah it's fun that's cool man that's
cool I've only I've gotten recognized I
think I've counted nine times nine okay
yeah around same around the thing last
time I got recognized it was like an 11
year old black kid hahaha I don't even
recognize babe I really small
everybody's like around my age were
younger we have very different
demographics then
okay I didn't know you got a guy oh yeah
I have two cats this one's called Todd I
got a black one to show not racist and
that's why I'm talking with you too I'm
trying to prove something right now Oh
per day um hey man what I have a
question I never asked you about
relationship stuff before I've been
talking about a lot of stuff but like
what's the longest relationship you've
actually had seven years wow really
eight years 88 years in a white sea miam
the ex I used to have on the show she
was um we were bed buddies for a year ah
ok if he got together your own each
other but yeah that you grew all right
yeah that's awesome groans my wares know
we'll just kidding what is going on with
you and Noel I'm get I'm constantly
getting text messages like once from you
and then once from her I'm like I don't
even know what's going on right now all
I know is you two need to talk to each
other little little man little man to
this little romance developing right now
I still gotta email it I'm gonna talk
about collaboration your tongue and what
it can do and all that see all right all
right you thank for ya so I will you at
dinner this is so awesome if something
actually happened with you two that
would be the coolest [ __ ] thing in
the world I I genuinely love that girl
like she's she's an awesome for human
being um I think she's a she's I can
really relate with her actually like I'm
a despite like the conversations you see
me out with these girls on-camera
off-camera we tend to actually have like
very meaningful kind of deep talks about
stuff and her and I really relate a lot
when it comes to like backgrounds and
upper innings and stuff and so yeah
she's a good friend of mine in you too i
think would be compatible and she has
said that she prefers a big penis mm-hmm
I mean a lot of girls who don't like big
penises but i'm going to assume you have
a big penis
so yeah well I'm not to the kneecap but
you know little higher than that that'd
be scary that'd be [ __ ] terrifying he
want to dick that big that it's so scary
no no one wants to dig that big really
oh my god that would hurt anyone this is
this I worked with a guy who told me he
got motive pity he got voted the biggest
dick on this college football too no way
he's also big [ __ ] a
nightwalker yeah he said he literally
and he didn't brag about when he was
telling me this story and he was telling
me about how this guy got voted the
smallest dick in the locker room I said
well who got the biggest he's our grid
unless the [ __ ] out of here and there's
somebody else that worked with his
cosine he was like nah man he's like a
horse [ __ ] I've heard about this yeah
from other people he said he had girls
turned him down literally say where are
you going to put that cuz you're not
putting it here yeah you know what's so
funny you're telling this like really
interesting story a dick story and i'm
looking at you going i could see how
this guy is a mentor to a lot of people
not completely disregarding that subject
i started thinking like looking at you
this guy i could totally see why a lot
of people look up to this guy like as
I've talked with you a lot on the phone
and I've seen shits out of your videos
but actually looking at you don't like
wow this guy I could see how we can
totally inspiring dude wouldn't i got
articulate my idea very well yeah that's
it yeah you're great communicator no
because like you show on your channel
that you do have like a sense of humor
but you also more than i do i think you
get a show your more like philosophical
side and beliefs on stuff like you have
the whole Magnus answer section where
you really do get a show more of that
psychological side because you took
psychology right yeah did and add that
in sociology they fought me a little bit
did you do you do like a lot of personal
element stuff like that's what i call it
some people call self-help but well yeah
I feel like if you come and you look at
my by bookshelf is I don't I'm read
anything but self l that's me too man
I'm not even jokowi helo home I am NOT
an occasional call me look that's boring
yeah no I think that it's boring it's
just that if I want fantasy I'll watch a
movie yeah and I tell you the truth
reading makes me tired for something so
it's like I have to read something that
I'm really interested with something's
gonna really help yeah no I'm set I've
probably read about five novels in my
life and two I read two books that are
autobiographies the rest are all like
self-help or personal development like
who would you say you're like like the
person I really looked up to was that an
e-cigarette there what is that an
e-cigarette no no it was my pin and I
was putting my gum on there so I wasn't
chewing through out oh I was like Tyrone
smokes without you ever someone told
someone left the comment about you used
to smoke weed yeah yeah was it like a
daily thing ah was it like a daily thing
um no okay well well I never bought weed
before but people always wanted me to
smoke with them considering you my
personality that you get to see it's
only modified and then you know
augmentin in that way but I remember
guys who always invite me over to smoke
and uh for what happened was there were
two times where I had adverse reactions
and I literally really felt like I was
gonna have a [ __ ] heart attack and
like oh wow so stop yeah stuff well I'm
sorry to hear that man like what I still
do oh god I live in California
we people up there it's uh yeah you can
get a card yeah it's not like legal in
stores yet but there's this fencer II
like in my city I live in alone which is
called van eyes there's tons and tons of
dispensaries like they're everywhere so
if you don't think like the people you
wouldn't even suspect to smoke weed
smoke weed out here it's like because it
because there's not as much of a stigma
it's such a social thing out here now
more so than drinking I think hmm I mean
there's like anything to you yeah I had
a buddy to had moved out there I think
one yeah his own like I guess we'd
orchard know that he was doing his own
thing out there and I don't know why he
came back he told me he was making good
money but I'm something happy would you
ever so long pull it out there right
yeah would you ever stop read again a
dead last time they last I'm really
scared I don't know but dude I'm going
to the east coast in September and i'm
planning on the sneaking so much weed on
the plane then go get on the plane but
you're gonna be able to go clapping but
yeah yeah if that happens then also I
total did your [ __ ] hotel room that's
like yeah as a Hollywood stories cutter
Oh Magnus had a heart attack because he
took a hit of a joint Susie coming out
in handcuffs well the light bulbs way
yeah exactly what uh what was the who
would you say are like the motivational
speakers or philosophical speakers that
you really looked up to for me it was
Jim Rohn mainly have you ever seen Jim
Brown yeah he's the one that folks like
profits are better than wages yeah [ __ ]
tyrone you know this [ __ ] yeah the road
I was like Jim Rome oh I would say the
two most influential books in my life
uh-huh were won by robert kiyosaki you
know that is rich dad poor dad exactly
uh-huh
and the other one was a natural cures
they don't want you to know Paul was
that type in sudo I've never even heard
that one yeah as a matter of fact and
you know what he's got kind of a bad rep
now I think he was caught stealing money
in criminy or so he was doing something
allegedly you know I don't know if he
did it didn't but he's got a bad rep now
but all the things in his book that I
tried worked wow I have nothing bad to
say about the man and you know I learned
a lot from him the netbook the mat in
fact I think he had gotten the
conspiracy theories you know there is
say that because he revealed so much
about the food industry and everything
like that they had banned him from
writing books for a few years really yes
so many people learn so much I mean I
really feel like he saved my life if I
met him in person i was telling you
saved my life because I was a little
really bad help before i read that goal
kick you know really know i feel like i
should read that what's it called again
natural cures they don't want you to
know about natural cures they don't want
you to know about and it's like what
what kind of book is it exactly is it a
nutritional type of book yeah but it's
going to explain you basically a lot of
reasons why you get sick you know and
what's in your food that's making you
see things they put your food that it
gift to 1230 at night you're like oh my
god need some [ __ ] McDonald's french
fries I do that almost every night yeah
you know if he says that they put stuff
in your food that literally has
addictive chemicals and like even I'm
not sure if it's in the book or not but
I remember him saying that McDonald's
calls people that visit McDonald's more
than once a week heavy users oh I think
I'll get you like your own [ __ ] you ya
know hey whenever you get those urges of
those taste for all those you know sweet
boobs you're addicted to a loud yeah
I've been
all that because my problem is I
easysoft video I used to be like
significantly less weight um what
happened with me like food was always a
comfort thing I don't know did you grow
up with like money at all no yeah I grew
a pretty Brook like I can't go into
details but my mom was like almost I'm
going into details right now she for a
while she was almost like a million
dollars in over half a million in debt
and so like it was really it was really
rough growing up and then when it came
to food I've been going to therapy a lot
lately again so I'm like realizing all
these things with when it came to food
like if we even got fast food because we
couldn't really cook as my dad was an
actual hoarder do you know what a
hoarder is have you seen like the show
or something yeah that my dad was of I'm
not exaggerating that's exactly what he
wants so we didn't have a place to cook
or anything like that so the oak when my
mom came home from work because she was
the breadwinner she would something
usually by fast food but no one ever got
like a full meal like you would have to
like split the burgers and [ __ ] oh so
that was like that for a large part of
it and then I so I don't know when I
started getting money i just started
wanting to really buy like a lot of food
and then likes tacos so it's like this
real emotional thing and I be eat
healthy for most of the day it's night
time when I start to like really get
craving so if I have a bad meal it tends
to be after dinner which sucks no and
that's what's keeping like I'm working
out eating better taking a lot of like
super high quality nutritional
supplements and then now I'm like oh god
I'm not losing belly fat because of this
[ __ ] food and it does take an
emotional toll on me